this package arrived just a few days ago
and i think i have a pretty good idea
about what it contains so
let's take a look inside
[Applause]
big amazon pouch
[Applause]
there you go it is
plastic out
this is a five pack there's
green apple
there's watermelon
[Applause]
there is
classic red
huckleberry and
last but not least blueberry
pomegranate so what are these these are
from the company uh
wiley wallaby this is the flavor that
i've had the most
of i've also previously once
had green apple and
my there's a little bit of a story here
why we actually got these
so i like red licorice among
other kinds of candy and licorice and my
mother-in-law
had purchased some of these and sent
two packages like this along to me
they lived just you know right literally
right down the road
from us and my wife came in and said
here try these uh
licorice that my mom thinks is really
great
and you might like as well and
they do live up to the really delicious
on the package
it's a different kind of licorice if
you're used to
something like twizzlers or you know a
little bit drier
in some respects chewier more
candy-like licorice these are a real
treat they're
thick they're moist inside
they have an incredible amount of flavor
they're not sugary the way other
licorices are
and you know you gotta kind of ration
these out if you're somebody like me
otherwise
you would eat the whole bag at once i
really like to have these
with you know as i'm watching a show or
something
with a big bowl of popcorn with butter
and salt
and then these every once in a while
when i when i bite into one of these i
usually take a little bite
chew that have a little bit more so each
one of these little links here
is you know you don't just pop it in
your mouth and chew it like a big wad of
gum or something like that
you savor it and you know they cost
a little bit more than than other
licorice but i think that there
there's really no comparison between
this and
other red licorice i really did like the
green apple
when i had it and we saw these
online that there were these other
flavors we hadn't tried
so each of them sounded pretty good
you know watermelon kind of an
interesting
taste for licorice huckleberry i think
i've only had that maybe once or twice
in my life in the past and then
blueberry pomegranate we thought oh
we'll give these a shot
so i'm actually going to do a little
taste test of
each of these so i can tell you about
them myself
personally in just a moment as
i open these up but i'm you know i'm not
going to be a
i'm not going to eat all of them i'm
just going to have one
of each and that's really my wiley
wallaby
ration for the day
all right so let's start out with
watermelon
it says watermelon flavored licorice the
perfect taste
of summer and
open it up now usually when you open
these bags of wiley wallaby
oh there's a very nice smell this one's
a little bit more
you could say taffy like but so there
there's what they look
like
same kind of consistency as the other
ones
definitely a watermelon taste to it but
it's not a like punch you in the face
the way their
more cherry-like one is
and it's it's a bit more faint but it's
definitely
all there it was pretty good so this is
this one's definitely a hit for me
all right i cleansed my palette and i've
already opened this one up blueberry
pomegranate two tastes that you see
paired together in a lot of different
products these days and that's got a
good that's got a good
smell to it as well there is definitely
like a blueberry
almost a dry blueberry smell like you
get in granola when you're you know
buying
granola that has a lot of blueberry
dried blueberries usually low land
low bush blueberries mixed in with it so
this one says where tangy meets tart
meets sweets so
that should be kind of interesting three
different flavor profiles mixed together
let's give it a shot
definitely pomegranate sort of undertone
in there definitely blueberry and
a bit more assertive flavor i think you
can say
than the previous watermelon one
not quite as delicate
it actually has a pretty good aftertaste
as well
so that one's a hit too now we get to
the one that for me is kind of an x
factor as i've mentioned i've had
huckleberry
in the past but i couldn't tell you for
the life of me what it actually tastes
like
because it's been so long this one is
labeled as delicious
juicy and oh so wild
so let's see if it lives up to that
reputation
that's that's an interesting order what
does that remind me of and look the the
links are a little bit smaller as well
oh no there's some that must be just
like i i picked a
little one by mistake there's there's a
full-size one right there
what is that i mean i guess that must be
huckleberries i don't i don't actually
i'm having trouble matching that odor
i'll
try
that one's not as strong it's more like
the watermelon oh it's got some real
sweetness to it though
not not a sugary sweetness but like a
fruity
sweetness so that's pretty good it's
kind of
like if you had black raspberry
and blueberry combined together in a way
i think it would taste sort of like this
um
so that that one's a hit as well
[Applause]
this flavor i already know that i like
the the green apple i like
other green apple things and the wiley
wallaby
green apple is particularly good the one
time that i've had it
oh you can even wow that one you can
smell from here
compared to the other ones and it's
definitely got a tart green
apple scent to it it says fresh from the
orchard
flavor so that does it does it really
taste like a green apple
i mean
it's it's not as tart as what we'd
expect with a lot of green apple stuff
there's a lot of
sweetness there and it's it's definitely
got a
you know imagine if you took a really
sour green apple
and took that tartness and sourness and
bite out of it
this is what you would have i really
like it
and so you know it's a hit with me
last but not least of course we have the
classic red which is um i mean they they
said it's strawberry but i think there's
also a bit of cherry
taste to it myself a delicious twist of
fruit chewy goodness
this is a little bit darker too you
notice when you look at it right there
than the other ones and i love it
i mean this is the one that got me
interested
in this brand definitely soft and chewy
i will say that some other things that
are nice
about this you know no high fructose
corn syrup
they list themselves as fat free and
vegan which i suppose you know
is almost trivially trivially true about
these but
those are good as well and so all five
of these flavors
excellent you can get them you know in a
lot of different varieties we bought
them in this five
pack because we wanted to taste what the
other flavors were like and so that's
uh pretty much all that i have to say
about this
this type of candy i really enjoy it
myself
and i think that you might as well
by comparison to other types of licorice
out there i think this is really head
and shoulders above
the rest
you